I'm so sick of hearing about this Snider
cut man that's never gonna happen
actually he's excellent to release more
images the other day really look at what
August trailers screen junkies still
going at it bought them all fandom
entertainer where they do screen junkies
news live from their home it's been
great still honest trailers Justice
League Snyder cut of course we gotta
watch this this episode is sponsored by
google play with the help of the battle
cats
[Music]
from the studio whose Sochi they wanted
to pay off critics like Marvel clearly
does hahahahaha single-handedly keeping
Pharaoh relevance left incredible
alternate those writers film since Colin
Trevorrow Star Wars Jodorowsky's dune
and the bundle cut of cats
Curly's attained justice lead the Snyder
cards already got an Oscar reports out
ready for Kenya to be the big payoff to
Zack Snyder's DC trilogy but when it
wasn't great fans knew the version they
saw was the water down result of a vast
conspiracy and demanded Warner Brothers
released the Snyder cut with a barrage
of petitions airplanes are some air
hashtag so powerful not even the dead
were saved
that's rude now this righteous crusade
is borne fruit in a cut that doesn't
just make Justice League into a good
movie it transforms it into the best
movie ever made and yes at once adding
in a young Dark Side origin story of B
story where Seidel travels to our past
to change the future nice and why did it
roll for Jesse Eisenberg Lex Luthor
another that's like CrossFit C in fact
everyone gets across Bitsey oh really
[Music]
nice also featuring the restoration of
Wonder Woman's original mustache
Hasenpfeffer man black steel Superman a
heartfelt apology from the cast of
Ghostbusters 2016 and Alpha Team his
favorite parts of Atlas Shrugged a team
over there oh my god yes if it's your
own free choice based on your judgement
for the value of that person is
struggling
it's brilliant youth this country showed
the rest of the world what greatness was
this goes on for twenty more minutes
always in the film that ends up longer
than Titanic but is so definitive it
shuts the door on comic book movies
forever
sorry Disney that's a wrap no wait -
making Kurt Russell talk robot let's jog
this trademark whoopsy dialogue it said
to Hell where the heads as the cast
returns to make sure all their lines
match the original tow right ain't over
yet
strangers movie clubs are killing Lois
Lane and blowing up all of Metropolis
goes nuts that burns a hole through his
head wait am I getting the DCU so
surrender your body mind and soul to a
film that's taking on mythic proportions
that exceeds your wildest imagination
hobbies into existence or this is all
been the ploy to boost signups for HBO
max crap we've been duped again haven't
we
Denis would remove a Schneider cut
tattoo from a lower back asking for a
friend
story the original cast of Justice
League Plus Lobo and Green Lantern come
on
hashtag the movie yes so true well this
was a fun April Fool's joke but
seriously finish the Snyder cut and put
it out so we can move on to demanding
the del Toro cut of The Hobbit the
finish cut of Suicide Squad and the
anyone else could have Game of Thrones
Season eight okay this episode is
sponsored by Google Play and my day is
ruined
do I look like a real boy papa this is
the first time in human history we can
save lives by sitting at home doing
nothing let's not screw this up Zach
Snyder I think he did some livestream
recently watch along and he was talking
about how like the Superman scream a
walk the mother boxes which segues and
adjust ously he talked heavily in depth
about the Martha moment and the symbolic
meaning behind the whole fight that led
right up to this moment and honestly
here in his perspective on it did make
me appreciate that moment oh it's the
little cheesy but maybe at least get
where he was
coming from in that moment and it was
nice to see that he had some ideas that
extended before that moment actually
occurred showing that there was actually
a buildup into it this honest trailer is
something that was incredibly creative I
thought because I love the bit I love
the approach that they took that this
movie has it come out there's been so
much demand for it and people have built
it up so much in their heads by this
point it is already the greatest comic
book movie of all time if so I love that
approach they took this bit it's gonna
put all the comic book movies to shame
and this right here is the best comic
book movie ever made because we as
audiences who really are obsessed over
it and really wanted I want it I do I
want this latter guy if anyone wants
cider cut it's Zack Snyder who wants it
out of here too clearly
you know what I think they should make a
sequel to this movie someday that would
be amazing that would really be
something else yeah I want to know what
happens to these guys I mean don't they
eventually having that been green in
your head with this like there's no way
I just can't imagine a world where it
could be as good as we are hoping it'll
be after so much time has passed it's
probably the greatest it'll ever be by
not having to be released no I don't
want imagination yeah I definitely love
the the angle they took with it because
as opposed to like dissecting the Snyder
II cut they have you know because it's
not out they managed to take a bit a
whole commentary about the way we are
reacting to wanting the Snyder cut so
yeah this is this was hilarious I
thought this was a really funny bit and
the voiceover work by John Bailey once
again knocked it out the park this was
awesome oh yes seriously well I mean I
forgot all about April Fool's being a
thing in the midst of all the chaos
going on in the world and so as a both a
gift a joke I thought this is great so
this is a piece of commentary because
yeah I mean the Snyder cut of Justice
League has taken on this whole other
life of its own that few movies I think
get to experience I think it's also
fortunate for them I was actually this
morning listening to more of the screen
junkies recap of his commentary I think
that's you know great timing for them as
well and it is fascinating to kind of go
back and see all these pictures that
he's releasing and then look at it side
by side with some of this footage I love
the
moments that they went in and actually
corrected like with cyborg and Aquaman
the whole I'm sad thing yeah I thought
was really great again a really creative
way to make a joke that's super relevant
but that's also really on point with his
points that it's making with its
satirical qualities and whatnot I love
the whole Atlas Shrugged bin at the
middle with the whole Jeremy Irons
impersonation because you know that gets
to something spiritually at the core of
Zack Snyder's expression that he and
viewed these movies with the excerpt
they chose was really perfect for that
it was really well edited yes it really
did look like they were all listening to
it yeah this was just magical to me I
think and it's true I'm very curious
about the Snyder cut release cuz the
more people talk and the more airplanes
get bought and more bus stop benches it
seems like it's actually gonna happen
and I wouldn't be surprised if that HBO
max thing is absolutely true it seems
like it keeps coming closer and closer
to fruition when you have the man behind
the camera the management the the Snyder
behind the Snyder guy being front and
center and I'm riding this wave for it
some stuff has been confirmed he has
said that there's some additional VFX
that needs to be done there's a rumor
going around that he needs to shoot a
little bit extra and I strangely feel
like Ben Affleck might be on board if
needed oh yeah because he seems to hold
something like well regard towards Zack
Snyder for everything it seemed like
after what happened with Justice League
it was it was especially burnt out for
him at all and then of course the
personal life struggles he was having as
well I do get the impression at least
just from seeing Ben Affleck in
interviews I don't know the guy I would
imagine that he might actually be a
little bit down to help out with this
Snyder cut especially because he was one
of the people you know retweeting at
least that they should go ahead and
release this so I'm excited for whenever
this comes out I I think one day it's
going to come out whether finished or
not it will be released in some fashion
but the longer they wait the more people
are gonna be probably disappointed I
feel like I can manage my expectations
on this I know how to tamper my
expectations but I feel like a lot of
people will probably come out ready to
go wasn't as good as everyone made it
out well it depends on if this is a
curiosity for you or if
is you know something you're gonna win
an argument or a debate with and I think
there are two very distinct factions
that exist right and how in that term
but guys what did you think of this
honest trailer make sure to go leave a
comment down below hit our like button
does help out with the algorithm make
sure to subscribe to strange onions if
you haven't done so already subscribe to
the real rejects click the notification
bell and before we wrap this video up
wanted to give some name call-outs to
some patrons who are pledged to our
deleted tastes some behind the scenes
get access to exclusive lead story over
at patreon so the TV show reactions what
not ads so we shout people at the
beginning of the month and at the end
the month and these folks are the last
four remaining are two so not only Turin
rien Sotelo
thank you
badass thank you guys appreciate it
seriously
you